hello this is rafa yaki and I have put
myself Damon money air hello demo hello
and we are from CD Projekt RED and we
would like to introduce you to gwent and
then it which you strike me as a man of
the world are you familiar with Gwen no
and I don't have time to learn but the
rules are quite simple come let's play
why not splendid here's how it's done
this is a card game that you will have a
chance to play if you decide to do so
when exploring the world encountering
NPCs and even you can have a big you
know tournament in novigrad if you
choose to you know pursue those line of
question because you can find new cards
you can find new things in the game and
we just wanted to highlight how the game
is played maybe demo we can take it from
here something that we haven't really
talked about so far so we thought we
needed to do a short video explaining to
you what gwent is all about it is quite
simple it's a game of two armies
compassion in you as a player you will
play the general of one of those armies
the rules are fairly simple you will
take turn and place a card on the board
which we call the battlefield and the
idea is that each card that you will
place is called the unit card and it has
a little value in the corner that value
will add up and the player with the
highest value will basically win a
battle now the trick is that you want to
get 10 counts at the beginning of the
game
and it's the best of three round at all
when the whole battle you will not be
getting additional cards to ring the
game there are some exceptions we might
mention them later on but the idea is
that you have ten cards and you must win
two games with it two matches and
basically when you place those cards you
can place them on three different areas
as we call them so the first area is
just Mally range as we call it so close
combat then we have range which is
archers and those kinds of things
bowman's and then we will have the siege
weapon the siege weapon and the siege
weapon the lobby students balusters
trebuchet is those kind of catapults
yeah catapults weaponry and this
simulates the battlefield as we
envisioned it in the same very
simplistic way you know to highlight the
the way the quaint is actually played
yeah this the strong theme that we
wanted to keep as well as have some cool
mechanics we wanted it to really make
sense so you have some special cards as
well which are whether Carson these
weather cards will affect all the units
on the whole row your units as well as
the enemy's units and even those we try
to keep with the theme so close combat
will be affected by frost if you play
frost all of the units close combat role
will see their values render to one then
we have fog focus for long range so the
archers they can't see because of the
fog they're not as powerful and then the
the last one which is rain rain sort of
affects the wood in the ropes of all the
siege weapons and will Brenda
then below weaker now there are a lot of
special cards we're not going to going
to show them all to you because we wanna
you know we want you to have fun go in
the world and find them yourself now
what we're going to do is show you a
video that record it earlier on actually
I was playing a game of Gwent as I often
do and I wanted to test out a new deck
we have four factions in gwent we have
northern realms we have nilfgaard sky
Adele and monsters and I was working on
improving my monster deck alright so
here you can see that I i had my initial
10 cards I'm just going to pause here
basically what you can do at the
beginning is redraw up to two cards you
don't have to but in this case I really
wanted to because you can see I have two
commanders horn and what that will do
that card will double the value of all
the cards on one row now having two is
pretty good but also have the ability if
you look at the bottom left corner you
see the the leader my leaders ability
the one that I picked for this
particular match was will give me the
same as a commander's horn for the close
combat unit so i didn't need two of them
so i decided to just get rid also had to
look at this lovely looking lady here
she's really really a very cool i love
abbraxa when she's all out in the open
all out as you would now you can see the
little icon
they're on the left and that's very very
typical of the monster deck it's called
master basically what i will do is that
when you place one of those cards on the
battlefields in this case a vampire card
it will call other vampire cards either
in your deck or in your hand so for me
having two of those in my hand is
actually quite bad because when I place
one I will lose the other one that's
also in my hand so I will be down to
eight cards after only one round so I
decided to get rid of that one as well
and hopefully not get another vampire
now I wanted to take a closer look at
discount because it's one of my favorite
sister so dragon and this car is really
hard to find as well when you will place
it on the battlefield it will kill the
strongest unit card of your enemy
assuming the total value on that
specific crow is higher than 10 does
that make sense the foam yep it does now
I know this guy has that card because
I've played against them earlier on and
I actually lost because of it so I will
try and be careful this time so my
nilfgaard faction started with a spy
card and the spy card is really cool
because you basically give the points to
the opponent but you get two new cards
instead
now I told you earlier on that the enemy
had that same dragon card so I didn't
want to put too many points straight
away on the board because I knew it was
going to burn me so instead I played
some ghouls and demo also used the goo
ability that he talked about earlier
which means that one goal will attract
others from his deck so the total right
now is 14 vs 0 because he was only
playing spice at this point now I wasn't
too sure what to play at that point I
decided to you up instead of playing a
unit card I played the horn so it
doubled everything on there another
another spy for nerve guard so at that
point the eye is really just trying to
get as many cards as possible I'm
already on 46 I feel pretty safe I
choose to pass and from this point you
cannot place another card only North
guard will play until they decide and we
see here the indeed played the dragon he
just played I'm gonna pause here really
quickly so we can see what's going on he
played the dragon burnt one of my top
cards then he scored burning another
card because the eye is aware that my
ability as a monster to keep a card at
the end of the round on the board so we
in here with 17 14 and I actually ended
up losing the round as you can see I
kept one card it's totally random it
turned out to be the weakest card
unfortunately okay and right now milgard
starts and they play yennefer which is a
hero card she brings back one of the
cards from the discard pile and that's
the dragon so right now they're at 14 I
decided to go with the vampires this
time fetch the other three so that's
really really powerful yeah it's 17 to
14 at this point the new guard faction
plays another hero card and the hero
cards are not affected by anything
within the game they stay on the board
as is
so as you can see when I play the dragon
the hero will not die heroes are not
affected by any special cuts they will
still go to the discard pile at the end
they will not be affected by anything
milgard brought up something from the
graveyard
so at this point there was three burns I
was quite upset about it I still had six
cards so I decided to just play it safe
and play a hero card and the drogue is a
hero card which is indicated on the left
corner to heathers the special on shiny
yeah right now it would 35 vs 27 and
it's Damien's my good friend Cirie
because at that point my my technique
was just to try not get burned and
obviously I have to win the last round
the I just decided to form it's a bottom
card I just went all out and trying to
save two cards for the last run now this
one is an important card actually I'm
going to pause hit you want to talk
about it the decoy card lets you fetch
to your hand a card that was already
played so if you can see that there is a
point at the game when you can benefit
from taking some card that you've
already played we play it again you
should do that with a decoy card it's
really good when bluffing as well if you
play your strongest Scout at the
beginning and the opponent will try and
match you thus wasting water this card
you can just decoy yours back into your
hand and they've span say 10 points and
as you can see nilfgaard has five cards
left and Damien has only three left he
just decoyed his dragon back and that's
usually a bad sign because that means he
wants to play it again obviously and
have its ability
but Damon has passed and Dai has lost
this round there's still five verses
free cards and it's important from this
point on to play very strategically so I
go with Eric ass which will fetch you
can see the bottom in fish is the daddy
haircuts or which is great yeah so we're
already at 22 fortunately I made a
mistake I totally forgot that he had
grabbed his dragon back so that burnt
the front row guys and I go for the
witches they fetch other widgets he
plays his sixth card which is 24 verses
13 at this point and one cards in Davos
hand so at that point I'm wasting the
weather card clear weather which will
get rid of all the weather cards on the
board the reason i do that and the i
also do that sometimes it's just to see
what else it can do now I didn't have
much of a choice I just had my generals
ability but I wanted to see anyway what
he had in hand because he had three cars
left so he plays very conservatively
another card that is mid value that
point I will pop my ladies ability which
will double everything and hope for the
best let's see if that is enough demo
okay he plays another five and because
they have a special ability they doubled
their strength now he plays the last
card which is five and that's not going
to be enough guys so we've one demo how
do you feel as a winner I feel pretty
confident this deck is clearly very
powerful I'm very happy with it I got a
bit lucky the AI didn't have any frost
cards to screw my close combat units but
as part of the game you have to adapt to
whoever you're playing against so
hopefully you guys will have as much fun
playing went as we had making it thanks
again for watching take care bye bye bye
bye
you